S
RONALD REAGAN SAID, FREEDOM IS
BUT ONE GENERATION AWAY FROM
EXTINCTION.
HERE WITH MORE, FLORIDA
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO IS WITH US.
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BUT
I DO KNOW THIS, SENATOR, THAT IF
WE -- THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE HAVE
SHOWN THE WILLINGNESS TO
COURAGEOUSLY FIGHT BACK.
IF WE GIVE THEM THE JAVELINS, WE
GIVE THEM INTELLIGENCE, WE GIVE
THEM STINGER MISSILES AND I
WOULD ARGUE GIVE THEM THE JETS
THAT THEY WANT, I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THEY CAN DO A GOOD ENOUGH
JOB WITH THEIR INSURGENCY
AGAINST PUTIN.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK YOU'RE SEEING THAT
PLAY OUT.
THE RUSSIANS ARE BRINGING TO
BEAR ABOUT 55%, 60, 65% OF THEIR
ENTIRE CONVENTIONAL FORCES NOW
INSIDE THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE
AFTER 20 YEARS OF MASSIVE
INCREASES IN DEFENSE SPENDING.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING A COUPLE
THINGS.
BAD PLANNING, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I THINK ARE ALSO SEEING SOME OF
THE RUSSIAN EQUIPMENT ISN'T AS
GOOD AS ADVERTISED BUT THE LAST
THING IS THAT WILL TO FIGHT AND
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
EASILY MEASURED.
I DON'T THINK PUTIN OR THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY THOUGHT THAT
UKRAINIANS WOULD FIGHT THE WAY
THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW, AND THEY
ARE PLAIN DEFENSE, THEY ARE IN A
DEFENSIVE POSITION, WHICH HAS
ALLOWED THEM, FOR EXAMPLE, FOR
WEEKS TO BUILD UP DEFENSES
AROUND KYIV SO I DON'T THINK THE
RUSSIANS ARE GOING TO GO IN AND
TAKE THE CITIES.
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO LEVEL THEM
LIKE YOU WERE SAYING BUT TAKING
THEM, THAT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH
TASK, ESPECIALLY KYIV.
>> Sean: WE HAVE AFGHANISTAN,
WE KNOW THE DISASTER THAT THAT
BECAME.
WE HAD OVER THE WEEK AND
BALLISTIC MISSILES FROM IRAN
SLAMMING INTO A BASE IN IRAQ BUT
THEY ARE SAYING WE WEREN'T THE
TARGET.
I'M NOT SURE I BUY THAT.
CHINA IS MORNING OF THE WORST
CONSEQUENCES OF ANY COUNTRY THAT
SUPPORTS TAIWAN MILITARILY.
SENATOR, YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I
DO THAT WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT
WITH TAIWAN AND WE ARE AN ALLY
OF TAIWAN.
ARE WE GOING TO ABANDON THEM
NEXT?
>> I THINK WHAT THIS IS
REMINDING US OF IT IS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF MANKIND,
ABOUT 5500 YEARS, IT'S LARGELY
BEEN THE STORY OF
AUTHORITARIANISM.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IN AMERICA,
YOU WERE SAYING IT IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE IN THE OUTSET, IT'S
VERY RARE AND UNIQUE, ALMOST ALL
OF HUMAN HISTORY HAS BEEN ABOUT
A TORT TO AUTHORITARIANISM.
NOW YOU HAVE AUTHORITARIANS IN
CHARGE OF SOME PRETTY POWERFUL
COUNTRIES LIKE RUSSIA, CHINA AND
THEN THEY HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
PLACES LIKE NORTH KOREA, AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET THEM IN
IRAN.
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE
IS THE NUMBER OF COUNTRIES
TESTING FREEDOM.
THEY VIEW THIS IS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO EXPAND
FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS.
THEY SEE WEAKNESS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THEY SEE
DISTRACTIONS AND COMPLACENCY IN
THE WEST, AND ARE WE -- YEAH, DO
I BELIEVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE PREPARED TO DO WHAT IT TAKES
TO DEFEND TAIWAN?
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT JUST KNOW WE ARE NOT GOING
TO HAVE THE SAME OPTIONS TO
SANCTION CHINA HIM AS WE'VE HAD
SANCTION RUSSIA WHICH IS
REMINDING US WHY WE NEED TO
PROTECT HER OWN ECONOMY.
ONE THING IS TO CUT OFF THE
RUSSIAN ECONOMY BUT RIGHT NOW WE
DEPEND WAY TOO MUCH ON CHINA FOR
THE THINGS WE BUY, WE HAVE TO
STOP THAT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I STILL FOR
THE LIFE OF ME CAN'T GET OVER
THE NEGOTIATIONS BROKERED BY
RUSSIA AND CHINA BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND IRAN AND THAT WOULD
TRANSFER TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE MULLAHS IN IRAN,
MAKE THEM RICH RIGHT OFF THE
BAT, BUT THEN WE WOULD BE
POSSIBLY, ACCORDING TO
PETE BUTTIGIEG, THE GENIUS THAT
HE IS, WITH ALL THE EXPERIENCE
HE HAS, IMPORTING OIL MAY BE
FROM IRAN, THEN POSSIBLY LIFTING
SANCTIONS WITH VENEZUELA AND A
MURDERING DICTATOR THUG AND
STILL JOE HAS BEEN BEGGING OPEC
TO INCREASE THEIR ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THEY KEEP TURNING HIM DOWN AND
HE DOESN'T TURN TO TEXAS,
ALASKA, AND OKLAHOMA FOR OIL,
AND HE DOESN'T TURN TO
WEST VIRGINIA AND OHIO AND
PENNSYLVANIA FOR GAS.
WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE THESE GUYS HAVE AN
AGENDA THAT BECOMES AN OBJECT OF
LIKE RELIGIOUS WORSHIP, RIGHT?
WOULD HAVE TO SIGN A DEAL WITH
IRAN, THEY ARE SO OBSESSED WITH
IT.
NO MATTER WHAT ELSE IS HAPPENING
IN THE WORLD WITH HAVE TO GET
THAT IRAN DEAL DONE.
DOESN'T MATTER HOW MAY PEOPLE
THEY KILL, MANY ATTACKS THAT
CARRY OUT, WE GOT TO DO THAT.
THE SAME WITH THE GREEN NEW DEAL
AND SO FORTH.
THEY ARE SO OBSESSED WITH IT
THAT ON THE ONE HAND MATTER WHO
THEY HAVE TO BUY OIL FROM F OR A
BARREL OF OIL FROM SAUDI ARABIA
WERE CLEANER THAN A BARREL OF
OIL FROM UNITED STATES, NO
MATTER WHO WE HAVE TO BUY FROM,
BUT BY NOT FROM THEM AND LET'S
BAG THEM BUT LET'S NOT PRODUCE
IT IN AMERICA SO THAT WE CAN SAY
AT LEAST IT ISN'T OUR OIL THAT'S
DESTROYING THE ENVIRONMENT.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST LUNACY, IT'S
NONSENSE, IT'S LEFT US
VULNERABLE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE WHAT COMMON SENSE DECISIONS
ARE BUT THESE GUYS CAN'T MAKE
THAT DECISION BECAUSE THEY'VE
GOT RADICALS IN CHARGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Sean: WHY ARE YOU AGAINST A
NO-FLY ZONE?
>> I JUST THINK A NO-FLY ZONE IS
NOT WHAT PEOPLE THINK IT IS.
IT WOULD REQUIRE GOING TO WAR
WITH RUSSIA.
WE WOULD HAVE TO GO AFTER ALL OF
THEIR ANTIAIRCRAFT -- THEIR
SURFACE-TO-AIR MISSILE -- NOT
JUST IN UKRAINE, WOULD HAVE TO
GO AFTER THEM IN RUSSIA,
BELARUS.
YOU HAVE TO BE WILLING TO SHOOT
DOWN ANY AIRPLANES THAT FLY OVER
THE AIR IN UKRAINE.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
FULLY UNDERSTAND, NO-FLY ZONES
ARE NOT SOME FAA ROLE THAT'S OUT
THERE, YET THEY HAVE TO BE
ENFORCED, YOU HAVE TO BE WILLING
TO GO OUT THERE AND SHOW PEOPLE
DOWN AND IN THE CASE OF RUSSIA
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO KNOCK
OUT THEIR SURFACE-TO-AIR
MISSILES.
THIS IS NOT SYRIA, THIS IS NOT
IRAQ.
THESE GUYS HAVE REAL MISSILES
AND I JUST THINK BEFORE WE GO TO
WORLD WAR III, WHICH IS WHAT
THAT WOULD BE, WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED TO -- WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED TO UNDERSTAND CLEARLY
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DOING
HERE.
>> Sea